la journée commence dans le quartier
donné rebond à copenhague
c'est ici que jonas viande a choisi
d'élever ses enfants
le parc n'est pas loin et la balade vers
l'école est courte mais dans le secteur
la vie a changé depuis quelques années
le terrain de jeu est devenu un repère
pour la vente de drogue
les commerçants sont intimidés par les
trafiquants
la violence augmente il y a eu des
fusillades jonas ne se sent plus chez
lui je ne veux pas vivre dans un
quartier où les gens se tirent dessus
pour s'attaquer aux bandes criminelles
il faut s'en prendre à leur profit et
selon jonas ça passe par la légalisation
du cannabis
[Musique]
ils surveillent de près l'exemple du
canada où la même réflexion vient
d'aboutir
l'idée gagne du terrain
copenhague n'en est pas à sa première
expérience avec le cannabis à quelques
kilomètres dans le quartier de
christiania la vente étant toléré tantôt
déprimé depuis des décennies des
transactions se font en pleine rue à la
vue de tous ce commerçant du secteur
quoi qu'il est plus que temps de
légaliser le cannabis
selon lui la répression n'a rien donné
ah ça fait soixante ans que on a fait
une guerre qui est qui et qui peut pas
être gagnée
jonas viande propose que sa ville ouvre
la voie de la légalisation pour le reste
du pays
le père de famille est aussi conseiller
municipal et c'est à ce titre qu'il
défend l'idée d'un projet pilote
une égalisation sur tout le territoire
de la capitale pour une durée de trois
ans il n'y a pas que des élus municipaux
qui milite pour la légalisation ici à
christiane borg le siège du parlement
danois des députés crois que le moment
est venu
cinq des neuf partis politiques
représentés à l'assemblée serait prêt à
suivre les traces du canada ceux ci un
petit peu jalouse
on a réussi à faire passer cette loi
ce dont sept députés la décision du
canada a relancé le débat au danemark et
pourrait aider sa cause son parti
l'alliance libérale aimerait que le pays
respecte de sa tradition progressiste
on a été le premier à dégainer ses
lapointe la graphie on a été très
progressif sur ceux de question de
mariage
homosexuels et autres et jamais on a été
aussi le premier a légalisé l'avortement
et j'aimerais qu'on soit aussi plus
progressif seul agenda du cannabis
la légalisation pourrait devenir réalité
d'ici cinq ou six ans croit-elle
mais des obstacles persistent l'idée
était populaire dans les régions rurales
du danemark et chez les organisations
policières
de quoi refroidir les autres partis qui
dirige la coalition de droite au pouvoir
centre
si les criminels ne font plus d'argent
avec le cannabis ils trouveront autre
chose fait valoir ce député du parti
libéral
opposé à la légalisation si ça
fonctionne au canada ça peut fonctionner
ici fait valoir y en as viande
soulignant que le mode de vie des deux
pays est semblable
les mentalités évolueront croit-il
persuadé que la légalisation aura lieu
éventuellement en attendant il est
confronté à une question déchirante
rester dans le quartier qu'il aime tant
ou le quitter pour protéger sa famille
de la violence tanguay
pendant que le débat s'étend dans tout
le pays
yonath bien fait face à son propre
dilemme ici louis blouin radio-canada
copenhague